but in fact one of the marvel cinematic
universes most powerful phase three
heroes nearly popped up in Avengers age
of Ultron well sort of according to a
proud owner of the pricey Infiniti saga
box set a deleted scene illustrates an
interesting tidbit disclosed by Marvel
Studios head honcho Kevin Feige back in
2015 that Carol Danvers aka Captain
Marvel was almost introduced at the
conclusion of that film you may recall
that age of Ultron ended with Steve
Rogers and Natasha Romanoff aka Captain
America and Black Widow assembling a new
Avengers team Toni starred was taking a
breather Bruce Banner was m.i.a and
Thoreau was off-planet investigating the
Infinity stones gathered at the Avengers
HQ was James Rhodes in his war machine
armor Sam Wilson aka the Falcon and new
allies vision and Wanda Maximoff also
known as Scarlet Witch the latter made
her entrance by flying into the facility
and eagle-eyed viewers noticed that
something about Maximoff looked just a
little bit off in that scene that's
because the special effects shop wasn't
designed for her but for Danvers who had
yet to be cast and the subsequent shot
of the new team assembled before Rogers
and Romanoff was filmed with a stand-in
for Captain Marvel front and center one
who was subsequently digitally removed
from the scene as pointed out by a
Reddit user who owns the box set the
unaltered shot is finally available for
fans to ooh and ahh over on the recently
released box set but Feige went public
with its existence shortly after age of
Ultron release speaking with birth
movies death and 2015 find that while
the good captain's inclusion was
actually part of an early draft of the
screenplay
he was never exactly on board with it
Feige explained Captain Marvel was in a
draft of age of Ultron but to me it
would have done that character a
disservice to meet her fully formed in a
costume and part of the Avengers already
when 99% of the audience would go who is
that it's just not the way we've done it
before you have no idea who I
I don't even know who I am
Feige went on to recall how he
essentially humored director Joss Whedon
who had gotten it into his head that
introducing an iconic never-before-seen
character during age of Ultron final
seconds
somehow wouldn't have confused the hell
out of the audience Feige went on the
way we reveal Scarlet Witch in costume
at the end of the movie
those were Captain Marvel plate shots
Whedon said will cast her later
and I said yeah Joss will cast her later
Feige then pantomimed whispering to
someone else adding quote we're not
putting her in there fortunately we
didn't eventually saw it Feige zwey and
the king geek explained that it was
actually the directors idea to reuse
those plate shots for maximov's entrance
Saiki dished finally Joss was like let's
use those plates to let Scarlet Witch
fly into frame give her a big entrance
and that makes sense
she's come to their side and she
deserves the crew intro which will feed
into another movie we start shooting in
a few weeks the movie to which he was
referring of course was Captain America
civil war that flicks first act hinged
on a terrible accident involving
Maximoff that prompted the world's
government to fast-track the adoption of
the sokovia accords
which required all superheroes to
essentially be registered government
agents whether or not to fall in line
caused a serious rift among the Avengers
leading to the titular conflict a
conflict which it's safe to say would
have gone a heck of a lot differently
had Captain Marvel been involved Whedon
may have eventually remembered that
giving out of left field unheralded
introductions to iconic heroes isn't
exactly how the MCU has historically
gotten down but before he did he had
designs on introducing another Marvel
hero in that final scene as well he may
have even actually done it had the deal
between Marvel Studios and Sony Pictures
to share custody of spider-man been
reached just a little bit sooner shortly
after age of Ultron release Whedon
visited the Empire film podcast to talk
about the picture and he casually
disclosed that if he had gotten his way
ol webhead would have also inexplicably
appeared alongside the Avengers in that
final scene according to slash film
Whedon explained I said it would be
great if we could just add a few more if
we could have a cat
marvel there and they talked about it I
was like and spider-man we could do that
too because Sony had approached us
during the production of the first
Avengers movie about a little
integration so I would have put both of
them in but neither of the deals were
made and then they were like we're
making a Captain Marvel movie and we've
got spider-man as a property and I'm
like I've already locked my film you
thanks for nothing
personally we're glad the friendly
neighborhood spider-man swung into the
MCU when he did but it's hard not to
wonder how things would have panned out
had Peter Parker left into the fray just
a little bit sooner Peter Parker hey
Peter Parker the Infinity Saga box set
has been released but good luck getting
your hands on one at the suggested
retail price of five hundred and forty
nine dollars and 99 cents the first
shipment sold out almost immediately and
they're currently going on eBay for
close to twice that hopefully Marvel and
Disney will get more on retailer shelves
in plenty of time for the holidays check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]